hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round seven of
the 2013 candidates tournament it's a
game between Boris Gelfand and Vladimir
Kramnik now the reason I decided to show
you this game is so I can show you more
photos of Boris Gelfand such as this one
no of course not that's that's only half
the reason I decided to show you this
game the other half of the reason is
it's it's a really interesting game and
it really does does you know follow the
old saying that the most beautiful part
of a chess game is very rarely seen on
the board you know if you don't analyze
the game after it was played you you
never even see you know the most
beautiful variation that could have
happened and another thing is it's it's
a really rich position that the theme of
the position that arises in this game
can very well happen in some of your own
games so you should you should really
study this position it's it's quite
excellent and I'm sure you'll enjoy it
and we don't have a couple of other
photos here we have a photo of gelfand
and kramnik a guy found with his usual
coffee and a glass of water kramnik only
with the glass of water but if you look
at their board from a different
perspective
such as this one you can see that get
fun brought additional refreshments
something more to drink and there is
something in that bag over there so he
could be expecting a very long game so
you know perspective matters so let's
see the game guys font has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight to c3 and
Bishop to b4 so the nimzo-indian defense
III we have castles and Bishop to d3 the
bishop attack against the nimzo-indian
d5 Knight to f3 and D captures in c4
Bishop captures on c4 and bush and c5
now castles C capture son v 4e capture
son d4 and b6 so this is I mean if you
really have problems developing your
light-square bishop sin in in any
variations against the d4 opening then
nimzo-indian could very well be the
opening for us here you will always have
a clear way of developing your light
square bishop so Queen to eat
we have bishop to be son and now Bishop
to g5 Knight B to d7 rook a to c1 Queen
to b8 and rook to d1 and here Kramnik
goes rook F to c8 so a very interesting
formation here at rook is still an a8
this rock isn't c8 and the queen is nb8
brush up to d3 getting this best part of
the way the Queen was defending it on c4
but you know that can change very very
easily
Bishop back to the six now eyeing that
h2 pawn if the knight ever moves g3 we
have a six and now comes the Bishop
captures on f6 Knight captures on f6 and
Knight to e4
we have rook captures on c1 rook
captures on c1 and this is the critical
moment of the game even though it's only
move eighteen here you can even see
magnus carlsen here studying the
position on the board Gelfand is very
confident in his position
kramnik is there studying it and as you
see cross and also is very interesting
is interested how a kramnik will handle
this position so there are a couple of
ways to handle this if you capture the
night immediately for example Knight
capture after Bishop captures Bishop
captures Queen captures you made it you
you allowed the White Queen to have this
beautiful active e Foursquare there's a
really no good way to kick her away from
there and although white is not much
better here it's it's a more active
position for white the rook is already
beautifully developed on the open sea
file the knight can come to g5 already
you can make some threats force force
black the weak in his position so not
really something you want to do after
this rook to c1 by Carson by a gate fund
the the most ideal thing you want to do
is play Queen to d8 now you have a firm
grip and on the c7 square the rook can
come into play via rook to c8 and also
the queen is now protecting the knight
on f6
if white ever decides to capture it but
here kramnik played a move that that
really could have taken a wrong turn he
played Knights to e8 and now if you look
at this position the Queen isn't b8 the
bishop and is on d6 and
better it really doesn't do anything as
both of them are you know hitting that
g3 pawn there's really really nothing to
do there the rook chronics rook is still
undeveloped on a 8 this bishop it's a
beautiful bishopman b7 but still you're
not gonna do anything with one good
piece and now you play this Knight back
to e8 okay you want to regroup but it's
hard to say if this is possible and
another thing this beautiful rook on c1
is controlling the c7 square and the c8
square so there's a really no good way
for for black to activate the Queen and
here after some consideration get fun
played nice to d2 with ideas of Bishop
to e4 and now this gave this gave
kramnik plenty of time to get back into
the game but here when you see a
position like this and when black makes
a move like night from f6 to e8 here
you're your chest alarm should
definitely go off you know your spidey
sense should start tingling and here as
the title suggests if the white pieces
were handled by a great adventurer such
as such as McHale tile for example then
you would definitely see a different
move than nice to d2 and it's a very
nice position for you to analyze not to
just pause the video for a couple of
seconds this is a position you want to
analyze for like half an hour or maybe
even maybe even a few hours so I don't
want you to analyze the position like
now to pause the video I want you to
pause the video and find its find some
ideas if you don't have a lot of time if
you have a lot of time to pause the
video then maybe you can even search for
something more but definitely try and
figure out how to proceed here as white
so if you found any of the following
variations then well okay you do know
that there is something in the position
so it's a bit easier then get it but
again you are an you are an excellent
attacker and for those who just want to
enjoy the show and I do recommend
everyone to enjoy the show here as this
is not easy the move you had to find was
either Knight eat the g5 or night f2g
five now Knight eat the g5 seems more
reasonable you're opening up immediately
a discovered attack on the h7 Square and
you know it seems like there are some
tactics here so
what can black do here of course black
can play g6 it seems like this stops the
attack immediately but after night
captures on f7 it's actually very hard
for black to do anything here in
captures night comes to g5 now there's
already an attack on the e6 pawn you
move the King King cap Queen captures on
e6 and there's really no defense against
Queen to f7 Queen to h7 so after Knight
e 2g v g6 doesn't really work another
idea is h6 so how does how does this
work well now comes the adventurer part
to really handle this position you have
to find this adventurers move after h6
you have to find Bishop to g6 and now
black has so many options but none of
them really work for example if you play
F captures here on g6 then comes Queen
captures on e6 with Czech you move the
King now comes Knight to f7 check move
the King and now comes knife 280 for
threatening Queen captures on g6 and
also when the knife came to have 7
there's also a double attack on the
bishop here so you have to prevent Queen
captures on g7 now white will simply
capture here you equalized material and
you're also a pawn up so it's a better
position you know you're you're gonna
win this with white so definitely not a
good idea for black another idea after
h6 and Bishop to g6 so okay you don't
want to capture a bishop how about
capturing the night
well then comes the other night comes to
g5 and now the Queen wants to come to h5
and also to h7 so after you capture the
bishop you prevent queen cap Queen to h5
but now again you get Queen to e6 check
King moves and now comes Queen to h3
check another move you had to find if
you already found the adventurers move
Queen Bishop to g6 King g8 now Queen to
h7 check King moves Queen to h8 check
King to e7 and now Queen to g8 and there
is no defense against Queen to e6 check
followed by Knight to f7 checkmate
ok there is a defense but you have to
give up the Queen you can go King d8 and
again white will go Queen to e6 and now
Knight to f7 with the threat of
checkmate is terrible and notice how
powerful the rockin c1 is like can't
develop any of the pieces on the Queen
side here you have to play something
like
Queen to c7 to prevent this move but
then rock captures and you're going to
lose this game the reason why this night
eat the g5 followed by h6 and Bishop to
g6 you've seen that you know it's really
hard to defend this from black but black
doesn't have to capture the bishop or
the night here he can go Bishop captures
on f3
but this also favors white but it's it's
very very very hard to find this Bishop
captures on f7 King to f8 and now Queen
captures on f3 you can either go Knight
to f6 doesn't really matter but even H
characters and g5 is a better move
because now you have to find rook to c8
for white simply attack that Queen on b8
and also you're threatening Bishop
characters on e8 opening up a discover
check from the Queen now comes Queen
captures Bishop captures and insects
would check Knight blocks and now Bishop
captures rook captures and Queen to b7
rook to b8 and Queen captures on a6
you're it's a rook a bishop and the
night against the Queen and white is up
three pawns white is better here and
because the King is so loose white will
always be able to you know make
something work here and in the long run
will win this position but that's the
reason why after this night to e8
although this seems like a more
reasonable move and it that white will
definitely be better here Knight F the
g5 is even better here now there are
some terrible threats
the queen is already threatening to come
here and whatever a black decides to do
here will definitely not go his way
for example h6 if you try to kick away
the night the Queen will come to h5
nevertheless now with threats of Queen
captures on f7 if you push g6 then Queen
captures on h6 so after captures you get
Knight captures here and now there are
some threats of Queen Jefferson f7 Queen
to h7 is a threat so after Knight to f6
there really is no better move this
powerful rockin c1 is totally crippling
Black's Queen side Knight to f6
preventing Queen h7 but now Queen
captures on f7 would check King moves
and now comes Bishop to c4 you want this
Bishop to capture the pawn then the
bishop is guarding g8
then white can white can simply figure
out how to win this now have crab Bishop
to d5 Bishop captures pawn captures now
comes Luke to c6 this is the the crazy
move you have to find and here black
really doesn't have a move you can't
really activate the Queen if you move
the Queen rook will capture Bishop if
you move the bishop that's even worse
let's say you play Queen to f8 maybe you
want to trade Queens now you'll get
Queen to e6 and black doesn't black
doesn't have a good move here Knights to
f7 is a threat Queen to h3 is a threat
the bishop now is attacked twice you can
simply capture the bishop so if you play
something like Bishop to e7 then simply
Queen to h3 King moves and our rook
captures on f6 will be a terrible threat
the threat is Queen to f7 checkmate
after you eliminate the rook again you
get this and queen to h8 this will be
checkmate
so it's very hard for black to even
react to this rook to c6 move if you try
something like Bishop to f8 simply get
the best part of the way rook captures
immediately wins wins the game for white
I mean if you capture it's checkmate on
h7 if you don't there's there's really
nothing for you to play here
so after this rook to c6 move it's
extremely hard to find to find a good
move even if even if black was was to
find that the greatest move which is
Bishop to f4 now rook captures and f6
will be met with Bishop captures and g5
that's the whole point of this idea
white of color of course will not
capture the night he will simply play
captures and after Queen captures now
comes the punisher and also a nice
little tactic for you to pause the video
and and find it I will give it a couple
of seconds win this position with white
so for those who found it
congratulations you are an excellent
tactician and for those who just wanna
enjoy a show here after after this
beautiful skirmish queen cap person g7
simply wins the game King captures only
move now comes to 9 3 6 check this forks
the king and the Queen King moves and
now Knight captures on f4 and now it's 2
extra points a completely winning
position for white and it's
it's very hard black will lose even more
points here so yeah here you can see how
much of this was possible in this
position after Kramnik played night to
e8 Knight to g5 was was a was a really
nice move and the knight f2 g5 was it
wasn't even better move but it would it
was it was a position where you really
had to spend time and of course get
funded didn't know there was something
here so he played nice to d2 and this is
why you should always analyze games
because you will find something
beautiful like this but okay get fun
played knight from a 4 2 D 2 and now
chronic played Queen to d8 we have
Bishop to g4 but rock to c8 and now
Queen to f1 elephant wants to try to
bring his Queen over to h3 Rock captures
on c1 Queen captures and now Quinta CA
to kramnik now offers the exchange of
Queens we have Queen to c3 now of course
if Kramnik captures the engagement will
improve his pawn structure Knight to f6
we have Bishop to capture some b7 Queen
captures and a knight 35
tonight's to d5 attacking the Queen
Queen to c6 Queen captures Knight
captures and now King to f8 a Kramnik
starts to bring his king over to the
over into the game nice to see for
attacking the bishop bishop to c7 and
Knight back to e3 Knight captures F
captures and now Bishop to d6 so now the
position is pretty much equal ok kramnik
does have to pawn islands and the bishop
against the three point islands and the
night so chronics position is definitely
somewhat better but not not enough to
make any progress here Knight to e5 we
have Bishop captures pawn captures and
mountain king to e7
King to f2 King d7 he for now King comes
to c6 we have King to b3 m c5 and King
to d3 and it was in this position on 36
so before they even reached time control
the players agreed to a draw so if you
remember in my previous video I said
that it's a three rounds than a rest day
than three runs then a rest day so it's
you know it's hard to say after a rest
day will there be explosions on the
board or will the players simply
continue resting and because all of the
games from round
seven were drawn it it seems like you
know the players continued on resting
but if you've seen the game I've shown
between cross and raja baath and now
you've seen this game were in this
position after chronic played in 98
there was definitely possibility for
explosions you know things could have
gone a totally totally different way so
definitely a wrong turn
you know this not night back move by
Kramnik but yeah I guess fun either
maybe he trusted Kramnik you know that
there really wasn't anything there
because chronic did spend time in this
position so he didn't want to spend even
more time so maybe he just trusted him
maybe he couldn't find because there
were really some insane moves you had to
find it to actually go for this wood
white but it's a beautiful position and
you know if tall had this position he
wouldn't calculate he would just you
know say there's no way to actually save
the hippo and he would simply gonna
either Knight to g5 who knows what he
might have played buddy I definitely
wanted you to see this and you know so
it's a lovely position and you know it's
a structure that might happen in your
own game so you should know it
definitely so yeah we don't have the
final standings the standings after
round seven so it's completely the same
as after round six
Carson and R&R with five points a share
in first place then we have sweedler and
Kramnik with three and a half Rajah
going rich with three and then Boris
Gelfand and vastly von Schuch with two
and a half so this was round seven and
we will not be showing any more games
from round seven so we've passed the
first half of the tournament so we have
seven more rounds and then we have
concluded the 2013 candidates tournament
and we move on to whoever wins this
tournament versus Vishwanathan Anand the
reigning World Chess Champion so yeah
that's it I would like to thank Nicholas
lean for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon with a nice game from
round 8 of the 2018 candidates
tournament thank you all and I'll see
you soon